HEY! How's it going' bros?
Did I scare you?
*wheez*
Welcome back to Resident Evil part 2.
Thank you for joining me on another episode.
We're doing this whole game together.
Just like good old times.
I don't think we finished the first chapter.
Ok we got a phone call.
Goddammit Zoella's in on this.
Goddammit Zoe.
Fuck.
I don't think I wanna go. (too bad)
I don't think I wanna go.
Uh the reviews are in on this game. A lot of people are praising it. I am so glad to be playing it.
I talked a lot about games and all that shit in general.
Uh but whenever I find a game that I really truly enjoy...
playing...
to be sharing it online with you guys is such a fucking cool thing.
Literally everyone is playing this fucking game on Youtube right now.
Like it's so popular.
But I appreciate that you chose to watch this with me. Out of all people. My god. Okay.
You know, when your girlfriend comes back to life..
that's a good cue, at least, you know, in my opinion, to just get the fu- just get the fuck out.
Also a thing that you bros pointed out was that in the VHS tape, they kick in the door.
And then all of a sudden, the door is back and not broken anymore.
Just wanted to point that out really quick while I pretend that I know where I'm going.
Oh we have the bolt cutter now.
Forgot about that, why don't we use it?
Hey! Look at that!
Why didn't we smack our girlfriend with that one? No offense. Hey there's the fuse!
W-we can use the stairs thing now. Let's do that.
WOAH!
Woah fuck, no she's back.
Oh my god I can't handle this.
My poor heart.
Fuck.
Uhm where's the cabinet? Here it is. Got it.
Pretty straightforward, I like this menu.
Pretty cool.
Pretty cool. I li- I like it a lot
Alright now we've done that. See I'm good at... *Jumpscare curses*
No it's not you!!
Where the fuck did she came..?
Don't stab me eh oh
Can you stop!?
Jeez
*scream*
How is my hand?
No... fuck.
That's the second time she did that. Pull it out.
Pull it out!
Pull it out.
Oh shit!
Oh shit!!
Oh oh oh hell no
Oh nope
*scream*
What the fuck!!
Jesus christ
But I fixed the stairs!!
Oh she sawed off my arm!!!
I wonder if the health pack... Use your health pack. That'll make it grow back.
Oh that's bad. (i didn't know that)
Ohhhh what the fuck!? lol
Fuck. Ah.
Ah ah, not on the painting. Jeez it's going everywhere. Ah god no I need to- (#nobloodlevolution)
I need to escape. (don't you like it here?)
Here we go.
Bitch.
Got 'em
Save. *laughs*
This is fucking crazy. Jesus Christ.
I think when your girlfriend saws off your uh arm with a chainsaw,
that's a good- that's a good time to just be like, 'mm maybe this relationship isn't working out.' (agreed)
Hey, there's the stairs!
That'll save my arm. (definitely)
Hello?
Yeah, don't mind me, I'm just bleeding out. (i love bleeding out)
No big deal.
Don't worry about it.
Did I give up on my arm?
See, remember before when I said we need to confirm the kill, alright.
Always confirm the kill. (i guess so)
We got handgun ammo.
*curses in Swedish*
Oh my god. Fucking.
I'm so on edge.
It's ridiculous.
Damn, you look good.. "Hey Pewdiepie"
Ah fuck, what was that?
Damn, you ladies keep rockin' man.
Okay, if we got handgun ammo,
that means there's a gun.
Where's the gun?
Oh my god.
More handgun ammo? Wh- Where's the.. pistol?
Okay? I suppose we go upstairs, I don't know how we climb these things. (earphone users might wanna take off there ear buds right now...)
*screams*
FUUUUCK!!
Oh I think we need a gun real fucking bad right now. (man pewds is able to point out some really non-obvious stuff huh?)
Umm..
I don't know. Don't hur- don't hurt them, they didn't do anything. (#ripmannequin)
Fuck. This bitch is fucking terrifying. My god, where's the fucking gun?
More ammo?! I don't need more ammo I need a gun!
*gasps*
YES!!
Get the gun! Get the gun!!
M719 mother fucker. (totally the name)
Can't reload with all this noise. Is she walking through the fucking wall?! (i love cutting through walls)
Okay, alright let's go.
Okay, well that didn't go like super well or anything.
Okay, it's a boss battle, I get it, I get it.
We gotta kill that bitch.
Hey Mia!!
Why don't you make a pizza?
Because your name is Mama Mi.. GOT 'EM!! (roasted)
Alright bitch,
Uh, just let me..
Got 'em.
Uh
What the
Okay, I think she seemed like a one-shot kill kinda thing
She's running
Jesus fucking Christ
Can you stop doing that?
It fucking hurt (actually you should be dead but whatever)
Oh my god
I don't know what you're talking about.
I hate when she charges! Fuck, it scares me so much.
Okay we're fine, everything's fine
This happens like every- every now and again (ok then)
Just uh- pour that on my little crippled arm. (rip arm)
Why won't you just fucking die?
YES!
Yes!! High- Fuck you! (you just killed your gf. savage)
Confirm the kill. What did I say? Confirm the kill.
Not on my fucking watch you're gonna come back again.
I'm just wasting ammo at this point.
But yeah, that's fucking right, I showed you.
I showed you motherfucker
That's fuckin' right, put one in the ass
*sigh* Aww she said I love you- I don't care! (savage)
You sawed off my arm! Mmm-
Uhh-
OHH SHIT! (jumpscared much?)
Stop. When will it fucking stop?
No- my face.
Great. *sigh*
Excellent.
Okay.
I see how it is.
Um-
He- did he just throw us out the house?
Man wtf is that?
Is that-
Like a cyclops? Cyborg??
Cyborg? Really Pewds? *laughs*
Really? I-
The ones with two heads, what are they called?
Cyclops? Right? No that's one eye.
Ogres! It's an ogre.
Ohh, what are they gonna do to me?
Wait, what?
Did she just fucking staple my arm together?
What the hell is that all about? *southern accent*
Now that's some crazy fucking-
Shit, all we need is staples? We've been doing science wrong all along.
Great.
Are you in- are you into this?
I kinda enjoyed the fact that we were gonna play with one hand.
But I guess I can- oh geez
Oh my god!
Are they wearing masks?
*laughing* Ohh shit- grandma!
It's good.
Not again?
Oh my god.
No, I don't wanna eat that
Euugghh- ew oh it's scare pewdiepie- eww
This is so fucking weird.
No
What the fuck??
I bet it's that cop-
Heh
This is fucking weird.
I wonder how my face looked like.
They still have my arm.
Granny! Psst! Hey!
Granny, psst! Come on, wake up!
Granny!
You gotta save me!
You're my only hope, Granny
Ahh fuck.
Hey I'm fine, how 'bout that :)
Granny?
We're gonna run away together.
I'm too old *old lady voice*
Shut up, Granny.
I'm gonna make it outta here alive, one way or another.
Mmm, the food looks pretty good actually.
Pretty good.
Alright where's the exit?
Where am I?
I'm disoriented.
Did the house change?
It did, didn't it?
The fuck is this?
Could this be a way out?
There's secured tape.
It can't be removed by hand.
Fuck.
Looks fragile, maybe you can break it with something.
Where did they go?
I don't think they're gonna be gone for too long. I better hurry the fuck up.
Oh look lovely flowers :)
Fuck.
Fuck!
I got it
What th- 'how am i gonn-'
JESUS FUCKING CHRIST
wHAT THE FUUUUUUUUUCK
Oh my-
Get the fuck- get away from me!
How much shit can i fucking-
No! Don't touch me please
Please, please, please I am poodiepie
I can't even see where he is.
Hatch key. Where's that go?
I don't like him.
Not a fan.
Okay, okay, okay.
Did we open up a new door or something?
Like a new room?
Maybe theres something in here
A fucking boot, excellent.
You know what-
Was that it?!
I AM WORRIED!
AHHH!
NO!
AHH!
We gotta get the hell outta here bros.
Ohhh this is bad.
This is real fuckin' bad.
Hey! a lawn mow-  antique coin!
Oh my god.
I don't like him.
It reminds me of Outlast. You know, the accents and all that shit. Fuck.
I'm just looking around to make sure I don't miss anything, 'cause I need everything I can find at this point.
And I'm kinda freaking out a lil' bit.
I'm kinda freaked out.
I feel like there's a lot of pressure on me... *pewds tears up*
to succeed here, because you're watching and I feel- you're adding pressure to me is what I'm trying to tell you.
Stop looking at me like that.
I'm doing my best.
Oh no.
Hello?
Oh god is he coming?
How do I turn off this fucking flashlight?
Thank-you.
Save. Saaave station, gotta love my saaave station
There we go. Fuck yeah!
Oh shi- no, no no no no
Yes, yass.
Thank-you.
I don't know why this family's such a bitch.
Don't know what I did.
You can store item, driver license.
Fuck yeah!
Who doesn't love a good... A house map! Okay.
Come on, give me gun.
Okay.
Alright let's combine... uhh to make a halfpack. Great.
We're gonna need that... shit for later.
Hey we're actually doing alright! How 'bout that?
You unlocked it. Yes!
By the power of the br- *phone rings*
Uh-oh
Who's calling?
Is it Zoella?
What's in your bag? Hahaha I don't care.
Dammit.
Hey, attitude Zoey.
Oh no fucking shit.
No that's an Apple watch. Sponsored!
Jesus Christ my hand! That does not look good.
Hell of a girl.
Hell of a girl, that Zoella.
I guess this is what she does in her spare time.
Well I suppose I will... leave this house now.
It's been a real pleasure. Honestly.
Like it's been, it's been really nice.
I- I've been having a lot of fun, you know?
It's been an eye-opening experience.
I think now, I will just like never come here again.
Probably have to see some therapy.
Probably just would rather kill myself at this point
than getting anything more done
to me
Um,
So the exit, uh it was uh?
It was here?
Maybe the coin?
Nah, that's stupid.
Well, I don't fucking know, honestly I don't know.
Okay well he's- is that a doll?
Oh my god, what the fu- *starts laughing*
Oh my god!
It's Pewdiepie! I love your channel bro
Ha
Okay.
Thank-you.
I forgot I have the block thing.
I seriously probably missed something, didn't I?
Let's look around some more.
There must be something I can do.
What?
Who the fuck are you?
Oh my god it's the cops!
Aw shit.
Okay, I don't mean to point this out,
but you know what happens to
To black cops in movies, alright?
He's not gonna help us.
What the fuck
Heh
That worked?
Oh okay.
Whew, okay we can use the-
We can use the knife to break the box
I just- i just fucking told you.
I love the voice actor of the main character.
Who is it?
Honestly, it's so good.
Okay, now we can break the tape as well.
Hopefully there's a gun in here.
No it's just a fucking switch!
Thankfully I have my Apple watch.
Thank you apple watch
Hey! It's you!
I looked for my girlfriend.
Alright, we should-
Ohh!!
NOOOOOOO!!!
Ahhhh shit.
Stop. Doing.
Ohh gun, gun!
Hell yeah motherfucker!
Hey hillbilly!
Oh fuck.
Oh no.
Oh no, senorita poodiepie.
Hey, hey, watch it.
Watch it.
Everyon- everybody- everybody sing
Oh god. It's charging.
Hey dude that's expensive equipment!
Can you fucking stop doing that
Aw fuck dude I got five more bullets.
Let me think of something, let me just think of something.
Oh, oh I see.
How do I get that down?
Oh fuck you're fast for being old.
Stop being so fucking fast, you're creeping me out.
I don't like you.
He clearly can't fucking die.
Yes I am.
Gotta problem with that? No? Fuck you.
Wtf did I just pick up?
Car key? Okay.
I'll take it.
Now I just gotta get this car going.
Not a problem, take my time.
Hey buddy how you doin'?
MOTHERFUCKER! *laughs*
Wh- OH MY GOD HE'S STILL ALIVE!
STOP!
JUST FUCKING DIE!
*cries*
Bahhh!
Ahhh!
HOW?!
Oh no!
You didn't call shotgun.
Nooo hahaha
Shut the fuck up *laughing*
Oh no what do I do?
What the fuck is up with this dude?
No, no, no-
Huh.
Oh
Oh my god.
Uhh, it's been great.
Ha, what a great date this was.
Ohh wow.
Hey man. Call me, alright? You have my- OHH NO okay alright don't worry about it.
Fuck.
Oh my god he's still fucking moving.
Are you fucking kidding me?
You best be joking, right now.
Ohhh- MOTHERFUCKER.
Jesus FUCKING CHRIST
*inhales sharply*
How are you still alive?
How?
He's not dead. Confirm the kill.
Confirm the kill. Have we learned anything at this point?
Confirm the fucking kill.
Confirm Kill.
cONFIRM KILL
*gasp* yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Up, up, up, up.
Go!
No don't-
Ah
Ahh
Come-
Uhh
Ohh, oh- oh, okay, alright.
Just gonna...
Just gonna-
That's fucking right, I spank ass
Okay, great.
I don't-
I though I would go up here.
Doesn't seem like he wants to...
Climb?
No?
Did I forget something? Maybe my car keys. *laughs*
Why is he not going up?
First aid, that's good.
Why am I not climbing?
Maybe now I can go?
Nooo! Fuck you, how is that even possible?
Dude-
Granddad-
What did-
What did I say?
I thought he was gonna show me his penis.
Okay, I have a- I have a strong feeling... that he's not fucking dead yet.
Just like a lil' - just like a tiny lil' hint. Based on the fact that no one FUCKING DIES
Hey, I made it. How 'bout that.
I swear... this fucking thing must- OK great.
So now I can take it.
Yes!
Fuck, man.
It's so hard to see.
Fuck, I hope that guy doesn't come back to life. I swear to god if he come back to life...
*laughs but is genuinely worried*
Oh my god.
It's all right, I have a knife *Australian accent*
You think that's a knife? This is a knife.
It's a tiny ass knife.
Oh my god, who did that?
Just give it up.
Here we go *sigh*
Who fucking built this?
Hello?
Hello everybody, it's ya boy, pewdiepie.
Hello everyone, wow what a... lovely home.
Where is the exit?
Shotty!!
Hoh-ho!!
Uh-oh
Uh-oh.
Uhh, guess I'll put it back.
Oh come on man.
Maybe we can take it, and then replace it with like... a knife.
Doesn't fit.
Well you motherfucker, alright.
I'll be back for you.
I'll be back, thank-you very much.
I'll solve that puzzle, bzzt- that fast.
Bzzt
Faster than you can say bzzt.
People who've already said it, fuck you okay? I have a knife.
*phone rings*
Ahh dammit, it's Zoella again. What do you want?
What?
Now you're just being wierd.
Jesus fucking Christ
I just killed her dad and she's like:'hehe you gotta hard time with your dad?'
Gunpowder.
Okay.
Another antique coin!
Oh, my favorite. My favorite thing.
Oh, this is where I came from? Yeah it is.
I suppose we will go upstairs.
But let's be careful.
Let's be careful now.
Granny!!
~Ah you promised you wouldn't go without me poodiepie~
Hey, Granny I tried to go with you.
I can't stab Granny. Dammit,*laughs* I tried to stab her.
Oh what a lovely house.
Maybe it's Daddy's hobby.
I would wear it.
Uh-oh.
Who's there?
Is that a lock?
It's a lock, okay.
It's fine.
Anyone here?
Another lock.
What we can't just budge it?
Oh we got amazing board games, titties, antique-
OHH HEY HI PEWDIEPIE!
Haha
Goddammit
Wait what does that say?
Marguerite, move that piece-of-shit hippy we caught from the hall to the processing area.
Not a VHS tape playing?
It says Mia on it, ooh let's watch it!
Let's watch it together and see what it says.
I'm sure it will be lovely.
Ethan, please watch this.
Mia Winters
Great, what a great movie.
Do not copy?
Is it broken?
Oh!
Here we go.
Oh well thanks, thanks a fucking lot!
Right. Sure.
Oh yeah, you were on your period? That's right? Okay, sure.
Oh shit I'm playing as her, what the fuck?
Oh geez, no I don't wanna
Hey babies how you doing?
~Oh my god it's poodiepie~
Goddammit babies.
Where the fuck are we now, babies?
Ahh fuck, ahh shit I guess-
Aww shit we're going here.
Fuck, okay, uh which way?
Wow what a lovely place, filled with wonders and...
Oh wow, it's my daughter, *nervous laughter,* I'll be right there honey.
Oh, yeah. Just mommy needs to go in the kitchen...
and kill hers- Goddammit. Are you fucking kidding me?
Uh okay honey.
That's fine.
I can't- I can't walk to you anyway you fucking moron.
Fuckin' piece of shit daughter.
What is this?
Oh I can walk in here.
What a lovely house.
What a lovely time... to spend together.
I'm having a great time.
This is wonderful.
Oh.
Was she just singing Shakira?
*sings* I'm sick and tired, of always being sick and tired.
Uh-oh.
Hey it actually fucking worked, Jesus Christ.
Okay great. I suppose we will go out the same way she came.
Excellent.
But what is this?
Now I can click it!
Oh my god it's a puzzle.
Uh, oh, uh-oh.
Oh okay I just had to press okay haha.
That's the most try-hard thing I've ever seen in my life. Jesus.
It's so wierd: I'm playing a game in a VHS tape...
In a game.
You know, I can't say I've done that before.
Not gonna lie, I'm not- this is the first one.
Just go through motherfucker.
Ah she's just gonna fuck me in the ass isn't she?
Just be careful.
Just be real quiet.
Let's just be real quiet.
Real fucking quiet.
Gotta be quiet.
Don't talk.
Don't speak.
Don't say a fucking word.
Just like I'm doing right now. Do not do what I'm doing.
Just not talk.
Everything is.. awesome.
Hey we made it to the other side :)
Oh my god!
Aww fuck, is this gonna be a reoccurring thing?
Aw she saw me.
Nope, she didn't lol
Jesus Christ!
I don't want your shitty gift.
You can take your Tiffany gift card, and shove it up your asshole.
Motherfucker!
Because you u-
Because you ugly mother fucker.
You straight up ugly
Heh-heh got 'em, got 'em.
Ah shit.
Hey look it's a picture.
This looks like it's part of something.
Uh-oh.
No..
*gasp*
NOOOO!
I can't-
Oh my god *laughs*
The fucking jump scares in this fucking game, I swear to fucking god.
I think I'm gonna have to end that episode there anyway.
If you enjoyed, let me know.
I'm loving all of the support we're getting on this year so far,
all the excitement, and I think it's so cool.
I love that I get to play this game online for you bros.
So thank-you, appreciate it, keep watching,
and I'll see you tommorrow,
Stay awesome, bros. *brofist*